That's so funny. He literally got like honey potted by like he
thought it was >> 21 year old who is who is like e-dating
a 17 year old. >> I don't know about the whole like the
whole thing that people are trying to like you talk to a minor.
I think that's really funny. I don't think he did it on purpose.
I think it is hilarious it happened on accident. I also happen
to find it funny that his ego is so big he's lost nearly a million
dollars fighting this legal battle with Pixie that he could have
just settled. I also find that funny but that's like an
Are are you going to bring Steven in or are you going to leave
him out there? I'm not bringing him in. I've already said I'm
not talking him to to him directly. He can ask questions or he
can point out where I've lied about something if he wants.
Okay. Well, um yeah, what else
I guess what what else did we want to cover tonight?
You're not banned from my Discord. That's incredible. I don't
know how he's not banned.
Um Um oh, yeah, just I I would just wonder like
I would just wonder what points that I've made that he thinks
are lies.
Yeah, I don't know. May- maybe he'll answer in chat. I I just
told him that you said no to him coming in. The I he could just
say like what I lied about.
Well, and let me pull myself up on screen and you on screen.
So,
I think in reference to this clip though cuz I think we were
trying to put a nice little bow on it. In reference to the bow,
you, like I said, most of the things that I had that were direct
quotes were Kelly Jean, Queenman, Lav,
Sunday, people who ostensibly were quote unquote on your team
but I didn't have direct quotes for you besides the infinite
rape machine. You've already said that you were descriptive.
However, you agree with this element of it. And then what I would
say is I pointed out the irony that I felt like you and Queenman
were super hot last year but you weren't covered in as much.
But you also explained that within our
um that effectively the the juice is not worth the squeeze.
And so, you know, I I mean I think that's like a rational argument.
>> going to be in chat most nights it might be worth the
squeeze.
Well, that's what I Dude, that's what I'm But this this is kind
of my point, man. It's like you you got Steven in the waiting
room. You could drag him in. You could probably boost viewership
by 30%. You would obviously increase super chats. You guys could
scream at each other, sperg at each other, call each other vile
names. >> I should pull the guy who's doxxed multiple people
in my community into my chat into my onto my stream? >> Yeah,
it's probably fire content.
I don't I Hold on. I don't want content like that. I don't want
him to go and like say somebody's name on my stream again. I
signed up for that once. And also, not only that, I watched him
debate with Pisco without a moderator there and I watched how
much he lied about Pisco. Lied about everything Pisco was saying,
right? Repeatedly over and over and over again. Just lied, talked
over the guy, wouldn't let anything happen, right?
And I have no interest >> I think I think in that conversation
I I don't know what the lie is. I felt like he was saying that
he felt like Pisco was overly friendly with a bunch of his detractors.
No, it was when Pis- Pisco was actually trying to extract concessions
on Destiny's lies. That was when he would just talk over him
and
Repeatedly. Um may I don't think there's any point having a discussion
with Destiny. He is a bad faith actor who will never have an
honest conversation. But if he wants to go ahead and say anything
I lied about from the chat, I'll pull one up. Hold on, he said
something. He actually made a claim that I said he had five cases
against him. I did not. I said you have at least with five people
shared the material non-consensually. That's true.
Where's the lie there? Each one of those people have said that
already.
Melina, Pixie, uh hold on. Abby, Melina, Pixie, I can I can do
this. Stasia and Cherry. Stasia.
Where's the where's where's the lie? That's like all all publicly
on the
Thank you for coming on. Yeah, yeah. Have a good night. Yeah,
you too. See you.
Sorry, I don't want to miss any of Destiny's messages. So, we'll
go take a look. What did he say?
There's a reason I've emerged. So, you didn't respond to what
I actually said
at all. Yes, he's okay.
Uh no, we're not going to do either right now.
Um okay.
I've already explained to you guys. I said this on the Wick thing
why I wasn't going to talk to this person. Nothing has changed.
So, I I'm not going to do that. But again, I'll respond to his
stuff asynchronously. No problem.
I'm just waiting for him to respond. Tell me where I said you
have five cases
How do I do this? I might have to I don't even know how I show
this on screen right now.
Okay.
Let me go find his logs and I will pull them up on screen.
So, I said, tell me where I've lied. I thought there were five
different cases and claims against me. So, I said there were
claims, yeah, not cases. Publicly available information.
You guys can say let Lav on but she's going to come on and say
let Destiny on and I'm responding to Destiny right now.
Sorry, uh Darius has to be banned from the Discord. Broke the
streaming rule in the Discord. Unlucky.
What's the difference between talking to him via chat versus
voice chat? He can't sperg over me and just like spam words over
me, right?
So, I'll just calmly respond to him if he wants to say what he
wants to say. But he knows he doesn't want to do that. He knows
he can't have that argument. He knows he can't have an asynchronous
argument. Destiny's going to sit in chat sperg typing. I mean,
he's he's typed like 100 lines already.
This is 0%. There's no reason, absolutely no reason to let somebody
on who's doxxed multiple people. Get Wick to moderate? I'm not
getting Wick to moderate. Again, if I'm wrong, if I've lied about
him, he can just I'm looking for where he's going to lay out
what I've lied about but I don't see it. If I've lied about stuff,
he should be able to point out things I've lied about with some
evidence and show what I've lied about. The Hasan strategy is
to avoid Destiny entirely. I'm saying he can literally just type
the things I lied about but instead he's going to run.
I've said repeatedly any asynchronous format he wants I'm totally
fine with. I'm just not going to stand there with him having
him rattle off doxxes with me around him. No, thank you. Yeah,
I don't know. I've said repeatedly I'm not doing the whole like
open conversation with this guy. I'll do it asynchronously any
I'm just waiting for him to respond but I guess he's I guess
he's gone.
So, the one thing he said was I said he had five cases of against
him. I've never said that, ever.
Let me on. I want to talk to Destiny through chat. I just left
the channel.
So, I'll rejoin. You can rejoin.
You can rejoin if you want, Lav. Go
Wait, she can rejoin, right? Yeah, she can.
All right, one sec. I got to reset my
Destiny, I know you're still watching
I know you still see things.
We used to be great together.
I DM'd Destiny last night.
What did I say?
I said
I said unban me from your Discord, King. He said never. I said
why? I'm on your side with the drama. Number one Destiny fan.
He said, you've got all your friends with Jstlk in his Discord.
Keep chatting with them. Smiley face.
He's so mad.
I don't It's so creepy. >> hold on. I just got to respond
to this chat message. You think I'm worried about the case Destiny
lost the case by fighting it. He could have just settled it.
He literally lost the case by fighting it. And the case wasn't
even something that existed yet
when the whole drama started.
So, I don't know. People are like trying to make it all about
the case. It's literally never been about the Pixie
Right? It's been about the allegations against Destiny.
Him having multiple allegations of sharing people's material
without consent. Him recording encounters without consent. That's
what this is about. It's not about the criminal case or sorry,
the the civil case. Nobody should ever do that.
Oh my god, can you hear Tim? He's yelling. He's fired up.
Who is?
Yeah. Can you not hear him? He's like
Jesus Christ.
I can't hear him at all. >> ban Darius?
Oh my god, he's like >> he's streaming cuz he's streaming
in the Discord when he's not allowed to. Oh, I thought that you
have a streaming
Oh, wait.
He was in the streaming channel. >> or something. Well,
>> I would rather him not stream any of my content though,
to be fair.
You moved him? Unlucky.
Damn. Oh, wait.
Wait. Maybe we can let him back. Maybe we can let him back in
to stream the stream now. >> I think you should. I think
you should. >> Yeah, maybe we can let him back in if they
moved him.
He's being he's being very kind. He He conceded everything. He
said that Destiny is a bad guy.
He said Destiny is a bad guy. He's in >> literally never
made.
He vouched for you. He said he's moving
Very cool, Darius. Hold on, I'm trying to figure out how to let
him back into the server.
One second, one second, one second.
Banned. Big vouch for Darius.
Darius
Darius IRL.
Revoke ban. Darius, back on the team.
Darius is your number one guy. You should give him mod. You should
just give him mod. While you're at it. Again, these people are
all like upset that I won't talk to Destiny. People who don't
chat in here are mad I won't talk to Destiny. I already laid
out why I won't talk to him. I said exactly how I will talk to
him, asynchronously.
Zero problem doing that. >> get back in chat. We know you're
watching. Come on. There's zero problem with that. He's fine
being in chat. >> Steven. I miss you. Let's spar.
I know you're sick of food shops. I know you're confused on what
food shops is.
I know you miss me.
Come back home.
Come on, big guy.
So, he lied. The first thing he brought in was a lie, right?
Oh my god, hold on. I need to go stop my husband from being
Oh, sorry. Hold on. What does this guy say? Didn't Lav do something
with like revenge porn? Oh, did Lav cancel another big streamer
who is his wife for doing like uh for sharing non-consensually?
Oh, wait. No, that was Destiny with Bob 7. Right. That was Destiny
with Bob 7.
Oh, sharing sharing these kind of images without someone's consent?
That should be career ending. Direct quote.
Wait, did Lav say that though? I don't know if Lav said that.
Can we get a Lav quote of >> What did I say? similar Lav
quote of you saying that basically posting someone's images non-consensually
is
It's awful. Never do it.
Never do it. >> She's doing it now.
So, Lav never did it. Never did it. >> should never do
I didn't say I never did it. I never did it. I didn't say I didn't
do it. I said I learned. I didn't do it. >> have her on
your stream right now. Again, look at this kinomorphic freak
right here. This guy literally exists in Destiny's community,
right? He exists in Destiny's community. And he's going to come
here and say, "Isn't it really bad to share some images without
consent?" You are a loser. You don't believe in this. You don't
believe this is true. You're a terrible person.
>> Both can I miss you. Come home.
Just absolutely no intention whatsoever of maintaining a consistent
Saturn standard. I'm going to hold you to a standard I never
try to hold up myself. I'm going to hold you to that standard
right now.
Good one.
You know what would be crazy if like it the situation would be
very different if Steven was like, "I shouldn't have done
Yeah, I'll drop I'll give her a What What she ask for? A 100k
at first? Or how much she ask for at first?
Oh, hold on. Was Was Darius calling to dox people in VC?
>> he'd have to get banned again. No, he
>> are saying this to me that he was calling for doxing
people in VC.
Yes, yes. A bunch of people are saying yes. Yeah, they're just
saying that. They're not That's not That didn't actually happen.
>> dox someone.
I was did not hear anything like that. He was They were saying
that he had uh he was getting um asked if he was a wild kitten
house at his house. >> you were like you were like muted
and
you didn't hear it. >> Maybe it was the time during I was
muted, but I I don't think that that's not the vibe that I was
getting from that
Forgotten Jones, you have basically said 15 iterations of that.
You can
I do believe this happened
in Darius's chat. Darius, chill with the doxing memes. I'm really
sensitive about it. It will cut content. Wow.
Okay, maybe Darius >> We don't joke We don't joke We don't
joke about stuff like that, Darius.
Uh I mean, you don't really get to joke about it when you're
taking one of Destiny's doxings. Just to be clear, you don't
really get to joke about it when you try to go to somebody's
house from a
Shouldn't have done that.
You need to change your name to something that's less of a mouthful.
Or like your community needs to be like called something.
We'll see. >> JSTLK is like so many syllables. JSTLK.
The JSTLKers,
are in a really rough spot now because I think I'm done with
this stuff. I'm going to move on to something else. And so, do
you want to sit here watch the fall of the Iranian regime with
me? So, we're going to >> god. That scares me.
Uh what am I looking for? >> I don't like talking about
what goes on over there in the sand.
I don't like sand very much. >> some stuff to catch up
with.
The Disraeliists, that's pretty good,
That is what we do.
That's actually pretty good.
Ha ha ha. >> Yeah, I really just wanted to come on to speak
directly to Destiny, but I will I will say before I go
It is No, I'm not Persian. Oh my goodness. Don't say things >> You
would only come on to speak directly to Destiny. That's totally
true.
Well, no. I only wanted to come on today to to talk to Well,
I I kind of wanted to talk to Connor cuz I thought it would be
funny. But I was respectful. I didn't join. I waited until he
was gone.
but I
uh yeah, I really just wanted to say that how pathetic it is
that Destiny is like in a 600 viewer at the time like 500 viewer
chat trying to like fight with you about himself. He really
handle it, which is crazy cuz he's like a streamer and he's been
streaming for like a decade. Well, but also what did he say when
people talk [__] about you in his community? You
remember what he says, right?
Well, just to not read it. Just don't read it. Just ignore it.
It can't really hurt you. It doesn't hurt.
Yeah, and he's like in your chat.
Yeah, and it's just so it's just so funny. It's You can't even
You kept saying that you don't think he's evil and he's not evil.
He's like just pathetic. He's just pathetic.
Destiny, have me back on stream. I'd love to be in another panel.
I miss those days. Um
you know, let's let's collab.
Let's collab.
Let's bring content back.
Come on. >> Yeah. I I don't think I have that confusing
a position. I'm like, "Oh, the stuff you've been accused of seems
pretty
Uh the stuff I have seen you accused of
that I feel you did, I'd like to see you criminally liable for.
That's the position. That's been the position
I also I also happen to find it funny that his ego is so big
he's lost nearly a million dollars fighting this illegal battle
with Pixie that he could have just settled. I also find that
funny, but that's like an aside. All right, that's a total aside.
I I think it's so fun. I mean, I don't know about the whole like
the whole thing that people are trying to like, "You talked to
a minor." I think that's really funny. I don't think he did it
on purpose. I think it is hilarious it happened on accident.
The Well, it seems
it seems like the minor testified or the minor like put in a
deposition
that she was not the one who talked to him
Oh, that's so funny. He literally got like honey potted by like
He thought it's so >> who is who is like e-dating a 17-year-old
and they were trying to sell her porn online. They started messaging
apparently.
But then doesn't that just blow up his whole thing where he like
trusted this person to share Really knew her. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah. It like kind of blows that whole thing up. So, it's just
very It's like very embarrassing no matter what angle you come
at it from. I think probably the best thing, the thing you could
most defend him with Oh, right. And the guy was a long time DGGer.
Like literally a long time sub for years and years.
So, that explains why he wasn't a fever
Yeah, it explains that Destiny >> content attracts those
people. That's that Destiny makes contact uh content that attracts
those people 100%.
Yeah, I was in DGG for a second yesterday and I got banned for
calling someone gay.
You cannot call someone gay in that community. As an insult.
Isn't that so
>> probably the only reason they would ban you, right?
That That's literally I was in there for like a week
chat chatting, being totally fine. And the moderator who banned
me literally was like, "You can't say gay. You could say but
you can't say gay. See you. Nuked."
I was like, "Okay."
I didn't even say it like that. They were They were like They
were mad at me for something and I said, "Well, that's No, he
said that he was gay. He said I had a boyfriend." I said, "You'll
never have a girlfriend." or something like that. He was like,
"I have a boyfriend." And I was like, "You being gay makes sense."
And then that's what got me banned.
So sad.
But anyway, yeah, that's all I that's all I wanted to say tonight.
Good luck on your sand content.
Hope it goes well.
Man, I tried walking away while she was like in the middle of
talking to go to the bathroom cuz normally I got a good solid
2 minutes or 3 minutes while she'll talk to herself. And she
just wasn't doing that at all.
She just didn't talk. Oh, what's up, Benny? How's it going?
Hey there.
How you?
I'm good. How are you?
Uh decent.
What's up?
Good to hear. Uh I'm just living life.
Living life? Have a good time? >> Yeah, yeah, yeah. Decided
to tune in when I saw that Connor
was on. I still hate Connor a lot. You love You love Connor content?
Yeah? That's cool.
Uh yeah, every once in a while it's good
watch some rage bait content. Um
I just wanted to say, you know,
although I agree that you shouldn't ever talk to
rancid, filthy, animal-like,
narcissistic sociopaths. >> Ooh. Um unless you can like
very clearly take advantage of them because they're just looking
to take advantage of of you. They're like the demons from uh
from uh Freeman.
You ever watch Freeman?
Well, I think I watched the first episode, but I couldn't get
into it. They're like demons and like they can like speak, but,
you know, they they don't they don't really speak like people
speak like to have a conversation. They speak just to like take
advantage of people and eat them. That's what a narcissistic
sociopath is like. So, there's really no point in even having
a a conversation with somebody like that, Destiny.
Although all of that is true. >> You won't get like good
faith like any concession they do in good faith is just under
the auspices of gaining something from it for later. And I mean,
maybe you could argue all people are like that to some extent,
but it's it's just it's pointless. I I again, I watched that
Pisco conversation that he had, and it was eye-opening when Pisco's
like just trying to get him to go like obviously you would say
that you were incorrect in what you said about me before, and
then he go no and then just yap about something else so Pisco
could never litigate the previous like lies. I'm just like, oh,
there's literally no reason to talk to this person. Yeah, that
[__] was it was very
I say all that. However, at the same time, you do kind of look
like a big fat when you don't have the conversation
Uh I understand that, but it's like I try to make it clear I'm
willing to have this conversation asynchronously.
Like I'm totally willing. If you want to say a lot about something,
go ahead, put it down somewhere. I'll respond.
Well, that's that's just how we roll,
I understand, but you understand that that's also just like it's
like all optics, right? It's not really a serious conversation.
Like it's not something I can respond to from him at all. It's
literally just I'm not having that conversation cuz he's going
to ask he's going to say, "Well, you said I had a criminal case."
And it's like, yeah, I'm not talking about it. Not talking about
it with you at all. Hey, Destiny.
>> What's up, Destiny?
Oh, is he back watching again? Yeah, of course he is. I It doesn't
show up on my chat overlay, so people have to let me know if
he's talking.
Yeah, he's he's talking. He said he said, "I'm so sorry for sending
Pixie's
uh nude videos to everyone." God, that's so big Honest This is
just This is He needed to do this all along.
Uh thank you for the six subs, So Box Society. Appreciate it.
Here's a super simple lie you tell. Why do you say the only issue
I had with Bob 7 was that he shared nudes of a girl? I didn't
say that. I said after you talked about him sharing nudes of
a girl, you said these allegations should be career
I do believe that's correct. If it's incorrect, I can just pull
the clip and we can try to find it right now.
Um Destiny, you would admit that you obviously told Melina that
you'd never share her uh non-consensually again after the Bob
7 arc, right? >> Destiny says, "What allegations?"
Destiny said, "Pull the clip. Why are you living in 20-second
clips?"
Pull the clip. Why are you living in 20-second clips? Hold on.
So, what was your most serious allegation against Bob >> you
know you're lying? That's what he
I didn't hop to another topic. I just responded directly.
The problem with Bob 7 was that he was the sole gatekeeper for
Austin's show and was pursuing girls who were applying to the
show.
Why have you never brought that up? >> as you've never
pursued anybody who came on your stream, I think you're in the
clear here.
I don't think he has.
Would you Or or maybe we could even be a little more here. Did
you never like share the nudes non-consensually with somebody
who came on your stream?
He said, "See the difference?"
See the difference?
He's right.
I think it would be frankly like vile for you to be like somebody's
sole career opportunity while having sex with them on your stream.
It's weird.
>> No one has ever had to [__] me to get on
my stream. Plenty of people have come on my stream before, believe
it or not. I haven't all of them. Not without lack of
Is that Wait. And then No, no, no. And then he he he actually
typed this. No, he actually typed this. He said, "Easy
lies, Destiny 1 0 JSTOK."
Here, I'm going to go ahead and turn you down so I can actually
respond to him. One second.
What was I saying here? Uh da da da da da.
Had to [__] me to come on my stream. Plenty of people
have come on Yeah, wait. Would this only be a valid argument
if you [__] every single person who came on your
stream?
Did Bob 7 [__] every single person who went on the
Raj Royale?
Is that what happened?
Is he even thinking about these things before he writes them
down?
That is pretty crazy.
JSTOK, when you and empath Oh, not JSTOK, sorry. Destiny, when
you and empath Chan had did your fluids merge and create
uh something superhuman?
Did her 5-year yeast infection and your phimosis feud
>> Jesus Christ. Okay, I need you to chill on trying to
be witty right now. Just chill. It would only be a valid argument
if I was gatekeeping someone else's show or even my own stream
behind propositions. Did Bob 7 only let people on who would send
him some content or was it like a an implicit thing? Was there
an explicit like, "Hey, I'll I'll put you on the show immediately,
but you can only come on the show if you send me
Is that what was happening?
I didn't realize those were the allegations. If those were the
allegations, then I am kind of wrong. Oh my goodness.
Oh my god, my husband's calling someone a [__] in
the other room. We We really are a power couple.
It doesn't really matter if it was explicit or implicit. Bob
7 was the audition person for Austin's stream, and he was
Oh my god, I'm having a stroke. Who is the audition person for
Austin's
Who is the audition I forget who the audition Who controlled
who came on Destiny's stream?
I think it might be Steven Bonnell the
There's no application process to go on my stream, and my stream
is my own my show. It's a totally different set of circumstances.
If Austin was people before they went on his stream, even that
would be significantly different.
Wait, is it worse because it's not his
The issue is that Bob 7 was literally the person running auditions
to get onto a show Austin hosted. So, it's that it >> Yeah,
I I understand what he's saying, right? I understand what he's
saying. But the power is in Bob 7. Bob 7 is apparently extracting
some favors based on having this power, right? Implicitly.
I think he thinks the outsourcing is the problem cuz he he's
I don't understand what he thinks the problem is. It's taking
the power from the the other streamer. Raj asked me to ask me
to go on his show. Oh, that's totally fine cuz it's his show
after all. >> worse because his role was literally the
person running auditions to go on his show. Steven, you were
that person for
Hey, this is not a good I don't know why he went down this. I
don't know why he went down this. What are you talking >> He's
probably got better things to argue. Why did he go down this
alley?
Pixie, are you watching this?
Pixie, if you're watching this, take these locks.
Imagine if I had a guy who gave out rules on my Discord and I
found out the only person who gives out rules was making requests
of the people going onto my stream. That would be insane.
Yeah, you'd be you'd be really mad because they'd be taking all
the
He's also not actually answering the question that there's obviously
a conflict of interest there when he's having relationships with
multiple people who go on his stream, and then he has a relationship
for that Sorry, a reputation for that that is perpetuating
How does he then know whether or not these people are offering
because they like him or they want to >> speaking directly
to me. Excuse me. Let me read this. Lav, you literally have made
multiple false allegations against other people, and you have
literally destroyed your life. You married your absolute last
resort and effectively cut out every other man you'd ever want
to marry for the rest of your life because you've now posted
extreme
online four
and he didn't finish.
I don't know if he meant to.
Oh, they're they're leaking that you asked to go back on his
stream? They're they're leaking that not realizing that you leaked
that yourself on stream? >> I just leaked that. I just
leaked that.
>> When did you first come on? >> laughing about
it. Well, let's let's let's both not speak. Just earlier, he
was like talking about you, you know, going off topic because
he can't be wrong and he's doing that right
>> Pardon me. Please let me respond to the allegations
about my false allegations.
You are Destiny, you are literally
going to court against something that I have accused you of.
We'll see how that ends up. 25 other women came forward about
Gabriel Gundacker.
He just totally got raped on the Bob 7 post and left. >> see
his day in court. He will see his day in court.
Um as far as the extreme goes with my >> you're you're
like talking a lot. I Dude, okay, finish. Finish.
Oh, I will and I do. >> reading his responding. It's so
Oh my dude, what?
Okay, go go Oh no, he said good luck. Yeah, he's leaving now.
Yeah, he ran. >> He's leaving now. He literally literally
he couldn't even defend the Bob 7 point, which by the way, I
could go watch those clips. If I misunderstand that he said these
allegations should be career destroying with like I thought he
was saying on its own the nude leaks should be career destroying.
Is that not what he was saying?
Yeah. Maybe hold on, maybe it was the combination of having the
power of who comes on the show and the nudes, but then again,
I really don't see how him having that power alone
I hope Pixie I think that you should you should send those chat
logs to Pixie. I think they'd be helpful.
Oh, the chat logs?
Yeah, of him saying that. He clearly
I think that that'd be helpful.
Why did he I don't even
I don't know what BBB gun just said. I'm trying to figure out
what what are these logs he just said shared.
Why do people keep saying wasn't as big of as it was made out
to be? He shared nudes of two girls to another one that he was
flirting with.
Oh, apparently that's like a big deal. Hold on, let me pull this
up on screen. Do we have these logs that got shared? Apparently
this was a big deal to Destiny 5 years ago. This part was like
a big deal that's about Bob 7.
But I'm like totally lying. I'm I'm totally lying, guys. I'm
totally I must be totally lying about this. Oh, your board of
justice feels case stream because Chad is a fat lonely loser
who's been now dumped by his
That's what he said.
Uh she was your victim first.
I don't engage with him talking about
He's like I I find it pretty good guys, so he does victimize
people and then he tries to talk them. This is like actually
unironically what the red machine is, right? Like the infinite
red machine.
Yeah, well, it didn't start with Destiny. It started with the
person who reported him.
Hurt people hurt people.
Disavow that comment.
We never actually know when the red machine started. It's infinite.
>> Okay, Benny, Benny, you wanted to talk more Sorry, what
did you Did you have a comment or a topic you want to bring on,
I don't think I had I don't I definitely didn't have a topic.
I think I just
I think I just wanted to say that
disgusting scum. That's it, really.
You know, same old same old. The usual. Wait. Yeah, okay, hold
on. Hold on. Let me Let me see here. Uh Destiny had his follow-up
logs from that same day. Kokainen, the nuke is that he literally
leaked two people's nudes to a girl he was actively
the other two girls to while being a producer of the Austin show
and he was pushing the girl who wasn't Melina to drop her nudes,
too. Oh, Destiny literally does this. Destiny literally loves
getting women to talk [__] about each other.
That's very funny.
That's That's very funny.
This girl sucked at giving head, but like about just so you know,
like here's a video of me getting head, but this girl sucked
at giving head. Cool. Cool cool cool cool cool. Cool cool
Guys, what?
What allegation did he make about Bob 7 that he doesn't fall
into? I Dude, I don't even He picked the worst thing to try to
stand on. Holy [__]
there's no way.
Okay. All right. Well, I thought I thought Benny would have more
to say. That's crazy.
He just forgot after he came in and he started saying what Cannot
believe that he said I cannot believe that Destiny said that.
Wow. I want to say Benny.
He's just like I don't He's just become
But you know, it's just because like like now that everybody's
calling him out, like he's just not a very good liar. Like he
I I guess I have to admit he sounds convincing, but he's just
not a very good liar. Like he just kind of lies impulsively.
I've been said.
Mr. Girl is right. About everything, every time, forever. So
sad. >> Yeah. Uh don't know if I agree with that. Definitely
the soul read on Destiny was 100% accurate.
I mean, look, you're not right about everything, either, so.
But Max is. Mhm. Mhm.
Destiny does this quite a lot, doesn't he? Listen, guys. What
you don't understand is when he traded nudes with a 17-year-old
pretending to be an 18-year-old, okay, when he got from her and
then retained that long after realizing the the the person's
age, that sounded bad, but he's actually totally saved because
he got those that 17-year-old's
videos from a 22-year-old man pretending to be the 17-year-old.
So, it's totally fine. He's totally
That brings very very similarly to the Bob 7 thing of, well,
guys, it would be bad for him to share all these nudes around
to people he But you forgot a critical element and that's that
he is not the producer of the Destiny stream, okay? He is not
the producer of it, so unlucky, you lost. He's totally saved.
I think he thinks well, this is actually true because his audience
is literally
that if he says something with enough conviction that it will
be true and it is in his echo chamber. That's always been the
case.
>> So, he can like but even when it's so clearly obvious
like this, he's not
I used to think that he had a very high
yeah, it's just very I I think he knows he knows his audience.
He knows his audience really well at this point.
Yeah, he can just do no wrong in their
Yeah, it doesn't even seem like it has anything to do with knowing
his audience. It's just like some of them are just so because
the lies like they're not even good. Like they make no sense.
It's completely and totally contradictory.
Um but some people >> the Pixie stuff.
Yeah, even on the Pixie stuff it makes like no sense. Like the
thing he said that was like a huge thing a huge revelation in
his hearing or something was that she sent the videos to her
boyfriend. I believe she put that in court documents like weeks
before that.
Like we Yeah, it was just it's like he just pretends things are
revelations. I don't think that was ever a revelation to him.
I think that was like the the idea when they originally made
the video was that it'd be shared with her boyfriend, but whatever.
Wait, Radiant Soul, you you understand I literally gave him
Wait, what are you looking for? If only we had a transcript that
contains testimony under oath that the victim was portraying
themselves as 18 and their target believed they were 18. That's
literally what I said at the beginning of the thing.
Wait, that's what I said.
That it was a 22-year-old man pretending to be an 18-year-old
using a 17-year-old
What part of that did I get incorrect? I literally said they
were representing themselves as an 18-year-old. I don't have
to lie about that.
I don't I've never had I've never ever ever Actually, I've seriously
never once implied that Destiny thought this person was 17. I
The closest I've come to that is saying I don't think he worked
very hard to validate her age. Okay, so Destiny I'm saying that
he hoped that she was 14.
Great guy. >> Yes, when Destiny was informed she was a
minor, he did nothing with the he retained, right? Except hold
on to
Under the auspices of, as he told Billy Mac, well, actually,
um if there ever is a police case, I want to have some evidence
to give them. The the white hat thing, the white hat Oh, I'm
going to keep this s- just in case the police ever look into
You understand that's like totally insane and that is 100% what
he told Billy Mac he was doing.
So, you could say there's nothing wrong with that, but if you
if you believe there's nothing wrong with that, that's
And didn't he say Didn't he say like 1 day before that to
Who's There was It was somebody on Twitter who hates him like
Ellie or something. He said something
Yeah, he said that uh like we were all pieces of [__]
because we weren't trying to find the guy who exposed the nudes,
meanwhile he's just sitting on all this while he's sitting >> Yeah,
he's sitting on all this child porn and not reporting it to the
police. He's just a filthy, disgusting It's It's like inhuman
the way that he lies.
It's so vile.
Uh flawlessly, yeah, without without any
I just don't Okay, yes, that's all true. What was I going to
I was going to pull up what Oh, also, by the way, we weren't
running with like the Rose is 17 thing. We weren't running with
that significantly, right? That might memed on on stream sometimes,
but before Destiny posted the PII required to dox Rose so that
Kiwi Farms before he did his collab with Kiwi Farms to dox Rose,
before that, we were mad about the known
The non-consensual recording, the non-consensual sharing. >> chat.
I know you're watching. Please
Come on. Come home.
I'm not done.
You're not done?
I'm fired up. I'm just curious why people think that a court
case on the least provable allegation
would put this to bed for anyone?
Him getting him getting catfished totally exonerates him from
his non-consensual distribution of intimate material. What don't
you get? Yeah, I I don't know where these people are coming
I don't know how they can get torn like Sorry, like
twisted into knots like this. I don't understand it.
Like do you guys remember what the original drama like with the
original problem was?
Non-consensual recording, non-consensual
Had nothing to do with Rose.
Sorry, it had nothing to do with uh sharing it who that it was
shared to.
Oh, if I Sorry, if I said I don't know where they're coming from,
I don't know where they're coming from mentally, Hunter, obviously.
In terms of like what community they're coming from, that's pretty
obvious.
I miss Stardust.
How? That's
Uh why do you have to say it so
Why couldn't you just say it like kind of sincerely? Like pretend.
>> I did I was being sincere. I I miss the old days. I
do.
I don't know, man.
I do. I miss the old days. We were on top of the world.
Thought it sucks, but
But now that I've done hardcore extreme with my husband, my whole
life is
Is it totally ruined? I just have to think about the old days.
It's completely ruined. I'm obsolete.
How extreme is it? I Not extreme at all. I don't know what he
I don't know what he means by
We're just We're having We're having love We're like telling
each other that we love each other. Boring.
That must be extreme for him.
Radiant Soul, I'm going to give you the opportunity right now
to come in argue
about like essentially how Destiny's been absolved based on that
transcript. You're You're perfectly welcome to come on and say
how he's been absolved.
Radiant Soul, you specifically. We will We will pull you in,
okay? You can come on the stream. You can come in. You can make
your argument.
Correct me if I'm wrong. >> I What? Go ahead. All right.
When when he was messaging Rose the first, didn't he say
"Hey, uh you can send me a picture of ID. Uh actually, never
mind. Uh just send me a picture of you holding a spork." Didn't
that happen? Something to that effect?
Wait, you got to say that again. I I didn't catch that. When
he first started messaging Rose or who he thought was Rose, didn't
he ask her to send him like a picture of her ID and then he's
like, "Ha ha, never mind. Actually, you can just send me a picture
of you, you know,
>> playing ball, dude. >> That would have been a
good question to ask him. Um are those leaks real? So, I think
we have some Twitter DMs that he apparently shared, reportedly
shared, and then he confirmed a lot of details of the person.
So, somebody basically reported this, right? And a lot of the
details of the person who leaked this stuff were confirmed by
Destiny, but not directly that like the stuff that got leaked
to Keemstar was real. So, that was in DMs that he said he like
tried to validate I think her ID and then she wouldn't send ID,
she just sent like a picture with like some maybe something written
on a note.
Yeah, that's what I mean. It's like when Lav said he was that
she thinks that he was hoping that she was 14. It's like if you
really want to verify, you just be like, "No, actually, just
send me the picture of the ID, actually."
But the fact that he was willing to just, you know, "Oh, just
send me a picture of you to make sure you're not a
He was hoping. He didn't even care like if she looked like she
was 14.
He just wanted the number to be low, I think. No, actually no,
I don't think. That's what I hear. Somebody said that
Anyways, it's been nice It's been nice chatting with you, fellas.
I think that he wished that she was 12.
I think that's very likely. That's a joke. Lav is joking.
It's It's plausible. I I don't know how likely it is, but it's
plausible. All right, see you later. See you. See you.
Destiny's back in chat. He just said, "I wish she was 10."
This guy sucks.
All right. Well,
that was fun.
I'll be honest, I Beyond the Counter-Points conversation, I got
no material for tonight, so I don't even know where we're going.
I think I was going to cover some of the
What was it? Like XQC responding to
XQC had some chat messages, right?
I think Holy [__] >> be I'll be back if I'll
be back if Destiny ever comes back. Let me know.
>> Yeah, sure. You definitely won't be back other than
that. Only if Destiny comes back. All right. >> Well, if
I'm If also if I'm bored or if I miss you.
All right. All right, we'll talk to you later. See
Yeah, yeah, there's some XQC stuff about the person.
XQC, that piece of [__] called MrMouton, a total
freak.
I mean,
Okay. Uh hold on.
Where are we at here?
Somebody linked this [__] Somebody just linked this
these
She read these messages on stream.
Yeah, I We don't have to go over the leaks. She read this all
on stream. She talked about this.
Did X make the comments about Ice chick that got shot? Yeah,
I know, that's what it was. I'm trying to find I'll try to find
these. Dude, I I'll be honest, I just I messaged Counter-Points.
I was like thinking about taking the night off from streaming.
And then I messaged Counter-Points and he was like, "Oh, yeah,
I'll hop on."
You're doing the Ice stuff? I got you an avatar. I did see that.
Now, I am kind of doing Ice stuff, so we should switch to it.
Give me a second.
Let me switch. Let me switch.
Hello. Hello.
The logs, right? Yeah, I'm looking for the XQC logs. Where are
these?
Hold on. I'll find them in a second. I'm just going to check
some of my channels and Holy [__] there's a lot of
people in the Discord right now. Lot of people in the Discord
right now.
Sure would suck to be banned from the Discord over a a meme earlier
today, wouldn't it? Would really suck. I'd be really sad if I
got banned from the Discord over a meme today of all days.
That would suck. I would be upsetty Eddie about that, okay?
Upsetty Eddie spaghetti, for sure.
Rose testified that Cy was the only person who actually informed
her about the leaks. Wow.
Did she Wait, she also testified that the that person harassed
her, right?
White names rules lowering? Just ban
Literally just ban them.
Just auto just ban them. Literally ban
Or is that what you're talking about? Cuz that's what I I literally
If you don't give me money in the Discord, you are lower than
trash, okay? Your opinion it means nothing. Your Anything you
want in that Discord means nothing, okay? You are lower than
trash.
That's how it is.
I don't even think we finished this whole Counter-Points video.
>> Where's the anger? Where's your rage? >> He says
something crazy here. I'm going to be annoyed that I didn't catch
it.
>> You know? Where Where's your Why Why can't Even if you
Even if you thought that Steven was getting off light, even if
you thought that the court case wasn't going your way, couldn't
you use this as an opportunity to be like, "Well, this is why
Steven's such a bad guy because he's been doing a doxing and
online harassment campaign in order to you know, intimidate his
detractors out of participating in the court case." Like can
you at least self-sweep a little bit?
Couldn't you at least self-sweep a little bit?
Okay. All right, fantastic stuff from Connor. We We love Connor
here. We love Connor, folks. We love Connor.
Trying to see if this will fix my headphones here. Why won't
you sweep?
Dude, I don't know. Oh, I also forgot to ask Destiny, does he
want me to cover the transcript or not? What leads to fewer people
being doxxed?
Should I cover the transcript or not? I legitimately will do
whatever gets fewer people doxxed. I'll not cover it if that's
if that gets fewer people doxxed. I'll cover it. If that gets
fewer people doc, gay. Just which one
Which one? Which one do they want?
I was I was challenged by CounterPoints on why I wasn't covering
it right away. So, I had a conversation on that.
Hold on. Let's see. What does Radiant Soul think? Is that guy
still here? Radiant Soul, should we cover the transcript or not
cover the transcript?
Which one?
Negotiate for Dan? Is Dan even gone?
What do you mean get Dan back?
Listen, I also I don't know if we could defend Dan anymore. I
don't know if we can do that. I don't know if we can make that
work.
What? Are you guys doing memes with Darius right now?
Why are you guys doing memes with
Hey, was Tan in the chat?
What did What did Destiny allege? You should cover the first
transcript where Pixie made a fool of herself. I don't think
she did. In fact, I might have to cover that transcript because
I think that's just been lied about completely.
I think the narrative that was presented on that got entirely
lied about. And for me, I was like, well, I covered the outcome
of the hearing. Like that hearing was a part of a preliminary
injunction. I covered the outcome. So, I was like, oh, I don't
have to go back and cover it. But, I might actually have to go
back and cover it to figure out where the lies are.
Which sucks cuz that would take so much
Sorry, did we get a Did we get a Radiant Soul determination?
What does Radiant Soul think? Should we cover the transcript?
Should we not cover the transcript?
Be good content for food jobs. Okay, well, I I will cover it
then. Radiant Soul believes we should cover it. Okay.
I will cover it.
I don't know if I'm going to do it right now, though. We'll see.
Wait. Do I have my timer? Oh, I need to fill up my timer. 25.
Uh we probably had like 3 hours on here.
3:35. 24. Let's go.
Let's go.
I still don't know how
I just feel like it'd be very funny to um not cover it repeatedly.
Unfortunately, I get pushed into this position where like these
people like you have to cover this right now. And I'm like, no,
I don't. And you getting mad about it makes me not want to cover
it more. [__]
What do you do in that situation, man? I don't know what you
do.
We should have Dan hop on the stream, shouldn't we?
What do you guys think?
Dan can't stream? Where's Dan at?
You know what? We don't need Dan. Could Hasan Could Hasan [__]
hop on the stream? Let's see here. Hasan
Hasan [__] dog striker, would you want to hop on
the stream?
Is this guy going to get on the stream?
Where's he at?
Oh. Oh, I paused my chat. God dammit. I was like, how is my chat
not moving at all? I paused my chat overlay. So, I literally
haven't gotten the last 100 messages. God dammit.